Kapaun morning use alone
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome sebastian voice Ahoskie
studio head people can fly
[Music]
all right good evening ladies and
gentlemen
I'm Sebastian wachowski studio head that
people can fly they stood behind
Bulletstorm and giza for judgment yeah
any bullets armed phones it out all
right Wow
let me tell you it feels great to be
here and feels amazing to be able to
finally announce outriders I'd like to
thank the team that people can fly you
guys are amazing and I know that some of
you are watching this life even though
it's 4 a.m. in the morning in Poland so
make a noise for them please thank you
thank you
and of course Square Enix for the help
and support has worked together on this
exciting new IP you know over the past
few years people can fly as grown to
over 200 developers and four studios
across Poland the UK and most recently
the u.s. to bring you what is our most
ambitious shooter to date to present
more to present more of our vision I
would like to take this moment to
introduce a short video from our game
director Bartok Mita so thanks a lot
more and outriders this winter
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
shooters are in our DNA it's our passion
and it's what we do I'll try ders draws
on all our experience from all our
previous titles it's a game we wanted to
make for a very long time we describe
outriders as a dark model shooter build
with traditional bodies by that I mean
we are creating an experience with a
strong story that you can enjoy with
your friends or on your own we want to
tell the complete story we are confident
we are building a shooter with a
powerful gun play incredible weaponry
and a hostile new world we want to spend
many hours in
it's it's a game of hand in our heads
ever since people can fly left epic
games
outriders is a one tool or free player
drop-in dropout consider in our game you
create your own outrider and journey
across the host a panel of Enoch is
search of the source of a mystery signal
it's a pretty dark and unforgiving world
and yes there is a lot more depth to the
game but I can't saved my fall right now
[Music]
[Applause]